The British discovered this region's treasure after
making India one of it's colonies
And building a road from Calcutta to Dheli
It provides hundreds of thousands of people
with their source of income
It can be applied to sensitive skin
doesn't clog the pores and is entirely natural
Without it the locals would starve to death
60% of the world's Mica deposits lie on
either side of this road
Under local law
digging for the mineral is forbidden
India's state of Jharkhand is
the riches of nature reserves
But everyone who lives here
knows that people still extract Mica anyways
Illegally
The process is based on slave labor
often involving child exploitation
Is anybody here?
Come here please
Hello
Suddenly two people appear
at this makeshift mine
The boy's father and their neighbor
from the village
The boy's called Vishal
and according to his father
he's 18
although he looks no more than
14 or 15
The adults seem to be scared that
the boy might let something slip
that should remain unsaid
Are you afraid of going down?
No Why?
At least one or two fatal
accidents are recorded in the Jharkhand Mica mines every month
It's not only adults who die
but children too
His body is covered in scars from contact with Mica
it's razor sharp
and working in a mine
the dust rises in thick cloud like
blooms
There's no time to talk
Vishal goes back down into the mine again
The mineral is extracted using the most dangerous method
It's scraped off the ceiling
where the rock looks as if it might collapse
at any moment
There's another fatal danger here
inhailing Mica dust often
causes lung cancer
The number of oncology  cases in Jharkhand is growing
at the alarming rate of 10%
every year
This is where people work
rest and hide from the heat
Average earnings for workign here
amount to no more than $3 a day
and all for extracting Mica
the material that is commonly used in
manufactured cosmetics
In 2014 the world's largest cosmetic
companies announced that they had stopped
buying Mica that had been extracted
illegally or by using child labor
They promised to bring in strict controls
over their supply chains
saying their Mica production
should never involve child labor
We're going to visit one of the biggest open mines in Jharkhand
It was once developed by a state company
but was abandoned when Mica production was prohibited